we are expecting the Prime Minister less
trust to shortly attend the conference
is of causatory Party Conference which
is taking place in Birmingham and there
she is there stepping out of the car
this conference is due to get underway
tomorrow and this comes of course on the
backdrop of controversies surrounding
that mini budget announced by the
chancellor quasi-quarting last week so
sending shock waves within the financial
sectors let's go straight now to Ali
forces queue who's in Birmingham for us
now and um Ali A lot of pressure then
being heaped on the Prime Minister list
trust and also on the chancellor
question what can we expect from them at
this conference
well I think all eyes are going to be on
Liz truss's big speech on Wednesday and
I think people are going to want to see
her appealing not just to the Tory party
faithful which she know which we know
she's always had a good rapport with who
we know have always been a fan of her
bold tax cutting plans what people want
to see is that she can make a speech
that will appeal to the market and to
the voters too after the extraordinary
polls that we've seen the last couple of
days giving labor 33 point lead so I
think what MPS disgruntled Tory MPS many
of whom aren't even turning up here
going to want to see is that this is a
prime minister that can deliver beyond
the conference walls because she is in
her element at these sorts of things
she's always been a Grassroots favorite
so she has arrived in Birmingham the
conference is getting well underway I
think you know this is ordinarily a
chance for a party to show off to sell
itself to the public last year the the
sense was very much very optimistic that
Boris Johnson some people talk about
Boris Johnson lasting another 10 years
how much things have changed in a year
and in a week we have seen Liz truss's
Premiership really coming undone as I
say extraordinary polls and
extraordinary context for this year's
conference perhaps things are slightly
better today than they were a couple of
days ago but we do have the devolved
Nations Finance ministers asking for an
urgent meeting with the chancellor I
think this is obviously going to be a
very difficult conference for the
chancellor as well but as you say Liz
truss arriving just know where we are
now in the center of Birmingham we were
inside today seeing some of the stools
getting set up everyone obviously
gearing up for the the Party Conference
but as I say you know the context is
very difficult indeed and not the sort
of of thing that the Prime Minister
wants to be coming into I think it will
be quite hard for her to get the respect
back of those Tory MPS I mean of whom
are very disgruntled
Ali in Birmingham at the Conservative
Party Conference thank you